[Music]
from a secret space man always watching
to the bar that appears in both the last
of us and Uncharted here are 20 secrets
and Easter eggs found in PlayStation
games in Ghost of tsushima all across
the land we can find the signs
indicating a bow by following that
instruction something marvelous will
happen every time it starts off as
petals and fireflies fill the air but
each new location the results change
around water the bow will see Rivers
once again filled with fish and around
the beaches well prepare for a crab Rave
so many of them a bird could come down
for a face to face but my personal
favorite are these frogs do indeed live
by the Frog shrines thankfully they all
know to get out the way of Jin's heavy
feet I'm outnumbered
strike faster in Spider-Man 2018 take
the time to enter photo mode when a
rocket is fired zooming in and look at
the details here right at the bottom
this rocket is guaranteed to kill
spiders amazing attention to detail over
in Detroit to become human when booting
into the game we can sit on this screen
here wait long enough and Chloe will
speak many lines she usually talks about
where you are in the story but it's
possible for this to happen oops I think
your saved game is corrupted
just kidding absolute cow bag recently
I've spent too much time standing still
in video games finding AFK secrets and
here's another one from Gran Turismo 7.
here at Daytona Speedway it's possible
to watch the launch of the SpaceX rocket
ship from back in 2018. it's crazy far
away but luckily we have photo mode
what's really cool and quite factual too
is about four minutes later when the
boosters needed to clear the Earth's
atmosphere will fall back down to earth
just like they did in real life where
would Elmo musk's mission to space be in
gt7 well that's because SpaceX sent a
car into space holy smokes man let's
lower the tone in Ratchet and Clank Rift
apart get your butt over to the bar area
and you'll be able to dance both lombax
have great moves and there's a lot to go
through but one of those is actually the
Carlton dance from The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air and I can't stop watching it in
God of War the 2018 game when kratos's
son was revealed as Loki the devs
couldn't help but throw in this very
short voice line I have beaten bigger
puny troll
puny troll which must be a callback to
the time the mcu's Loki fought a big
green troll like being
puny God puny troll
this one's a little freaky now in
Spider-Man Miles Morales take your time
to use Photo mode at the entrance to
Miles apartment look at some of his
neighbors they include Andy and Buzz
from Toy Story and is that Freddy
Krueger and Jason Voorhees I don't know
about you but I'd move out as soon as
possible another unsettling Easter egg
can be found in stray the cat game with
a dedicated meow button use that meow
near a CCTV camera and it will
acknowledge you with a nod
showing we are being watched constantly
because cats can't be trusted
another video game with a constant
Watcher is returnal the never-ending
time Loop has an astronaut which can
randomly appear and stare from a
distance the thing that really makes
this stand out is if you break eyesight
for a mere frame and the astronaut will
vanish completely making everyone
question if it really did happen
PlayStation video games love to add
Easter eggs referencing each other just
look at kratos's entire book collection
every single one of those is a
PlayStation game well did you know about
this in Infamous Second Son our
superhero our super villain character
has a very particular mobile phone theme
have a listen
oh you've got to be kidding me could you
place the reference it's the theme tune
from Sly Cooper thieves in Time
in Horizon zero Dawn a double Easter egg
can be spotted as one of the old
civilians is seen wearing this strange
necklace and another has these
futuristic handcuffs these were all
taken from death stranding which at the
time was only seen in a trailer but when
death stranding finally released the
Easter egg was returned with Eli and
tall neck appearing as Holograms in this
universe leading some fans to speculate
that maybe the two worlds are actually
one and the same
Horizon forbidden West and Ally's
mechanical archery by venturing over to
the soy area it's possible to see this
ax stuck in a tree someone left an ax in
that tree
is cold
left it here
check for a trail with my focus if
you're like Halo you only want to know
more follow the clues and it will lead
to a familiar looking Shack if more
clues are needed to who owns this place
then take a peek in the outbuilding
laying there is a handsome carving of
Kratos himself Legend has it there are
more God of War characters to find
around eloy's World trust me
you're gonna wish you had one an Easter
egg which many of us missed for years
was found in Uncharted 3. at the start
of the game when everyone else is
preoccupied with a pub fight the more
eagle-eyed were able to go over to the
bar and spot this newspaper the title
reads scientists are still struggling to
understand deadly fungus fast forward a
few years and that ended up being an
Easter egg for a game that hadn't even
been released yet that small article
would end up being the beginning of the
entire Last of Us story and the funny
thing is
precated as
was remade in the last of us as
some sort of perfect symmetry here and
then two games later Uncharted 4
released and this trend continued in
chapter 12 of The Campaign deep
underwater it was possible to find the
remains of a diver who had Crustaceans
living on their face which kinda looks
like a clicker from The Last of Us to me
right so when The Last of Us Part One
was re-released I was down to hunt for
another Uncharted secret but instead an
office Easter egg was found the American
version of the UK TV show was recreated
as part of the world and most of us
walked through this without noticing but
yeah this place is from a TV show okay
there's one more from The Last of Us
Series this time in part two and the
scene in which Ellie sneaks into an
enemy area taking down alas who is
playing a PlayStation Vita when it's
dropped to the ground take our time to
look and listen to it here's the music
for help
can you identify the game it's Hotline
Miami I love that game great touch over
in God of War Ragnarok and a missable
conversation when exploring the world
Mamiya will ask Kratos a very important
question brother I've heard my share of
stories about your Homeland but I'd also
heard that you once fought in a
tournament I fought in many contests but
this particular one I heard you did
battle with beasts Scoundrels princesses
the undead automatons and History's
Greatest musicians tonight
that's not true is it it turns out that
this is in fact confirming that
PlayStation All-Stars is a Canon part of
kratos's Journey he really did battle
PaRappa the wraparanco the beasts
Scoundrels princesses the undead
automatons and History's Greatest
musician okay
look less unsettling to end in the
ill-fated Order 1886 we run around
London chasing down werewolves but
should we have a look around we'll
eventually find this it's Sackboy a few
hundred years before he had his own
PlayStation game okay I plan to end this
video with an Easter egg from Astros
playroom but I couldn't decide which one
as almost every game in this list has
its own Easter egg in that game so okay
I've decided astrobot as Sam Bridges
from death stranding and look there's
even a tiny baby Astro strapped to his
chest perfect Chef kiss I'm Adam you
survive to the end of another video Stay
awesome I'll see you next time